foreign
last week Ryan went over to chat GPT and
he said hey I need you to write a
minimalist children's story
this one is called mini the minimalist
Mouse
and here's what artificial intelligence
wrote on our behalf and I just want to
point out this is unedited
yes unless you edited it I did not yeah
all right this is like complete AI once
upon a time there was a little mouse
name Minnie Minnie was always surrounded
by clutter and mess and her tiny mouse
hole
and it made her feel overwhelmed and
stressed one day many decided she had
had enough
she wanted to simplify her life and live
with only what she truly needed
so she set out on a journey to become a
minimalist Mouse what a smart Mouse
she started by decluttering her mouse
hole
she got rid of all the things she didn't
need like old scraps of paper and broken
toys she kept only the things that
brought her Joy like her cozy bed and
her favorite book
next mini started to be mindful of what
she brought into her life
she realized that she didn't need to buy
every new Gadget or toy that she saw
instead
she carefully considered each purchase
and only bought things that she really
needed
as many continued on her minimalist
Journey she found that she felt lighter
and more free
she had more time to spend on the things
that she loved like reading and
exploring the world outside her mouth
soul
you are a child I'm so immature I can't
help it it's like an eight-year-old that
was inside of me this is definitely a
chill house
I have kept it in long enough
oh my God a book that will turn any
adult into a child oh my God oh my God
all right keep going keep going all
right return the text
many even inspired her Mouse friends to
try minimalism too
they saw how happy and peaceful she was
and wanted to experience the same in the
end many realize that minimalism wasn't
just about having less stuff
it was about focusing on what was truly
important and living a life filled with
joy and purpose and so many the
minimalist mouths lived happily ever
after with a clutter-free home and a
Heart full of contentment dude I mean
clearly clearly
like and I saw you uh put on Instagram
the other day I don't know if it was a
tweet or maybe it was a picture of your
Tweet on Instagram but TK you were
talking about how with AI like it's not
going to replace that
human
emotional heartfelt
um aspect that creations have and and I
and with this I feel that it's missing
well either someone's if someone told me
that they wrote this themselves I would
just
I would feel like they were really just
obtuse and unaware of
um hey how many times they use mouse
hole in that story
and also Minnie the minimalist Mouse
like it's clearly like there's a human
element missing from that but here's the
argument I want to get for ai ai what I
like about the idea of it is that it
will give you a structure like this and
then you get to add the human the human
aspect to it and that to me is what's
really exciting because I people are
they're so mixed on AI and I think it's
everything that everyone thinks it's
going to be but I think there's
something that I don't really hear
people talking about I think you're
going to actually see art get bumped up
to a different level because of AI yeah
I agree I've got no problem with AI
um
I
for me
I my position on on the chat GPT stuff
is that
the ability to generate pretty or or
poignant sentences in an efficient
manner is not a substitute for the
internal process of wrestling with ideas
and what that can do to the soul so in
an analogous way I value having machines
that can do heavy lifting for me right
when we move from South Carolina to
Southern California I don't want to
carry those boxes by myself I didn't
want to physically run for thousands of
miles I like having machines that can do
that for me but the strength of a
machine cannot confer muscular
development on me right it doesn't make
me strong it allows me to experience the
benefits of having that strength and so
if I want to be strong if I want to
develop muscles I still have to do
something to develop that and so there's
an aspect of writing that's really about
personal transformation that's about the
the cultivation of of critical thinking
and creative thinking and
using something like this to create a
story can give you output and that's
awesome you know what I mean but but it
can't give you
that process of moving things around
inside of your own soul that makes you a
certain type of person and so I think we
need both I think hey use that if it
helps you and at the same time don't
stop writing for yourself because that
does something to you it's it's a kind
of spiritual practice if you will did
you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free